10 IKT cybersicherheitskonferenz im
Wiener Messezentrum nach zwei Jahren
corona-pause ist die Erleichterung
spürbar groß wir sind ganz einfach froh
dass es stattfinden kann weil die
letzten beiden Jahre mussten wir sie
leider Corona bedingt Absagen daher
freut es mich umso mehr dass es heuer
eine so große Veranstaltung in die
größte bisher hier in Wien ist weil
dieses Thema immer wichtiger wird ich
glaube wir dürfen bei all dem eines
nicht vergessen worum es am Ende des
Tages geht es geht um Sicherheit es geht
um die nationale Sicherheit um die
Sicherheit von uns allen Sicherheit im
Internet betrifft nun mal uns alle ob
wir wollen oder nicht und das nützen
kriminelle immer wieder gerne aus das
Problem sind die größten
Herausforderungen wie man deren
Aktivitäten in den Griff bekommen weil
die lassen sich immer neue Chinesen
enthalten ich glaube die größte Gefahr
ist sehr schwer es wird viele Gefahren
sein und es ist wenn man auch zum
Beispiel bei run zum Angriffen sieht ist
es immer und es ist die aus dem
einzelnen Angriffen die eine große
Gefahr macht also es wird es wird
weiterhin verschiedene Schwachstellen
geben wie lockfortjay die letztendlich
dann das Netz kurz durcheinander bringen
also da muss man darauf vorbereitet sein
und es wird immer eine Vielzahl von
Angreifern geben also man darf einfach
nicht denken man wird es mich nie
erwischen sondern man muss letztendlich
auch auf Angriffe vorbereitet sein und
Gewissen Notfallplan haben dass wir uns
einen erwischt dass man weiß was man zu
tun Sicherheit im Netz ist in Österreich
nach wie vor ein stark unterschätztes
Thema allein die Zahl der in dieser
Sparte fehlenden Fachkräfte spricht für
sich die österreichische
Wirtschaftskammer spricht davon dass in
Österreich derzeit 28.000
IT-Leute fehlen und das ist kein
militärspezifisches Problem sondern
trifft alle Unternehmen die solche Leute
brauchen und es werden zunehmend mehr
Fakten die schon seit längerem bekannt
sind und trotzdem ist Bewegung auf
diesem Gebiet weniger
erkennbaren teilen
aber politischen Entscheidungen noch
nicht so weit entwickelt dass man
tatsächlich quasi ist Strukturen
schaffen würde oder Weichenstellungen
vornehmen würde dass man da ernsthaft
was auf den Weg bringt und selbst wenn
man die jetzt stellen wird und zwar sehr
rasch stellen würde würde sie Bienen in
der nächsten fünf bis zehn Jahre gar
nichts tun das sind nämlich die
ausbildungszeiträume die wir brauchen
bis dann tatsächlich Leute dass diese
Systemen rauskommen und das gerade jetzt
in Zeiten von Energiekrise und Ukraine
ist dass der Krieg sich quasi verändert
wir haben also früher die mechanisierte
Kriegsführung gehabt also das klassische
Bild mit Panzern Schützenpanzern dass
wir auch jetzt noch sehen aber es
entstehen mehrere Ebenen und das ist
also einerseits von einem deswegen der
Fall weil die zunehmende Digitalisierung
dazu führt dass diese alte mechanisierte
gregierung zu einem Informationskrieg
wird oder auch zu einem Krieg um unsere
Haltungen und unsere Köpfe das ist die
sogenannte kognitive Kriegsführung und
das erleben wir jetzt sehr gut in der
Ukraine denn hier ist es so dass nicht
nur auf dem Gefechtsfeld quasi gekämpft
wird sondern eigentlich auch bei uns im
Wohnzimmer wenn es um die Frage geht
soll man die Ukraine weiter unterstützen
oder nicht und das immer mitten genau in
diesem Krieg drinnen die man schon auch
als modernen Teil deshalb übrigens
bezeichnen kann und mitten in all den
Krisen fehlt dann eigentlich nur noch
eins der seit 2019 immer wieder
angekündigte Blackout wir sollten
eigentlich für jede Minute oder jeden
Tag dankbar sein wenn es nicht passiert
und dass die Einschätzungen daneben
liegen wobei wie gesagt es geht nicht um
einen konkreten Zeitpunkt sondern dass
die Gefahr deutlich zugenommen hat vor
allem in den letzten Monaten durch den
Krieg und viele andere Dinge das sieht
man auch am Strommarkt und daher auch
weiterhin die dringende Empfehlung nicht
wann kommt endlich sondern wie können
wir uns bestmöglich darauf vorbereiten
und hoffen dass man das nie braucht
bestmöglich vorbereitet auf die European
Cyber Security Challenge waren die Teams
aus Dänemark Deutschland und Frankreich
mit dem Plätzen eins bis drei das Team
aus Österreich kann mit Platz 10 einen
Achtungserfolg einfahren